نتائج قمه الناتو في فينيوس ليست افضل ما
كان يطمح اليه الرئيس الاوكراني خاب امل
بلو دي ميزيلنسكي بغياب جدول زمني لانضمام
بلاده الى الحلف لكن الحلفاء طمانينه
بضمانات امنيه طويله الامد
اعلنت دول مجموعه السبع اطارا لابرام
اتفاقات ثنائيه بينها وبين كييف تضمن
امدادها بالاسلحه لعشر سنوات
دول مجموعه السبع تطلق واعلانا مشتركا
لدعم اوكرانيا سنساعد اوكرانيا في بناء
دفاع قوي في البر والجو والبحر لاستقرار
المنطقه ولردع اي تهديد
الضمانات الامنيه مهمه جدا لشعبنا وهي
تمهد الانضمامنا الى الحلف وليست بديلا
لعضويتنا فيه هي بالتاكيد نجاح مهم يمكننا
القول ان نتائج القمه جيده ولكن لو تلقينا
الدعوه للعضويه لكان ذلك مثاليا
هذا هو الاجتماع التاسيسي لمجلس الناتو
اوكرانيا مجلس يجتمع فيه الطرفان
ويتشاوران ويقرران كنظيرين متساويين خطوه
تجعل اقرب من الحلف اكثر من اي وقت مضى
الحلفاء واقر ايضا حزمه مساعدات لعده
سنوات تحقق مزيدا من الموائمه بين القوات
الاوكرانيه واسلحه الناتو
لا يمكننا ان نسمح ابدا لموسكو بان تقرر
من يمكنه ان يصبح عضوا في النيتو روسيا
كانت دائما ضد اي توسعه للحلف متى تصبح
اوكرانيا عضوا في النيتو هو امر يقرره
الحلفاء واوكرانيا وليس لروسيا امكانيه
نقده
يخفق العالم الاوكراني في كل شارع في
فيديوز ليتوانيا وجاراتها من دول البلطيق
تريد عضويه فوريه في الحلف لاوكرانيا
فالجناح الشرقي للنيتو هو خط مواجهته
الامامي مع روسيا عضويه وان كانت تبدو
حتميه في المستقبل الا انها تبقى مؤجله
الى موعد غير معلوم
في قمته هذه التي يصفها بالتاريخيه يكبر
الناتو بعدد اعضائه ويزيد من عديده وعودته
ويقترب اكثر من حدود روسيا لكنه يبقي
اوكرانيا على عتبته دون منحها العضوي على
امل ان تكون الضمانات الامنيه المقدمه
جسرا يقود الى انضمامها المستقبلي للحلف
الاطلسي محمد المدهون الجزيره فينيوس